[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without him hello
everybody welcome to episode 43 of the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is Joshua fields Millburn okay
so back in 2011 2011 a year after Ryan
and I started the minimalists comm we
published our first book it was called
minimalism live a meaningful life well
five years later toward the end of last
year 2015 we decided to update that book
we we created an app really different
second edition not only with a beautiful
new cover but every single page in that
book was refined you see what we were
reading that book minimalism to create
that second edition last year we were
astonished by how well the books
principles have endured during every
event every interview every podcast and
nearly every conversation we have with
our readers we find ourselves constantly
returning to the the five values that
were in that book the five values of
living a meaningful life the new edition
of minimalism live a meaningful life has
been available in paperback as well as
an e-book for the last year or so but we
recently asked our friend Justin Moloch
he's the the talented narrator over at
the optimal living daily podcast we
actually we hired him to turn this new
edition of minimalism into a beautiful
full-length audio book just like he did
with our other book the the essay
collection essential well guess what
once again Justin did not disappoint and
we are so very pleased with the final
product that he produced so pleased in
fact that we want to share a large chunk
of that audio book with you for free on
this podcast so what you're about to
hear is the first 45 minutes from
minimalism live a meaningful life read
by Justin Moloch
now just to be clear this isn't just a
snippet or a free sample of the book and
we're not publishing this podcast just
to encourage you to purchase the full
audio book rather we're trying to give
you the books first two chapters where
Ryan and I detail many of the events and
all the anchors that led us to a life of
minimalism and we're trying to give this
to you because we think that you will
find value in this content regardless of
whether or not you want to listen to the
entire two-hour and thirty-nine minute
audio book but if you do find value in
this episode then yes of course you are
welcome to download the entire
unabridged audio book over on audible or
iTunes or Amazon and we'll put the links
to all three of those sites in the show
notes of this episode so whether you
listen to the entire audiobook or you
just listen to these first 45 minutes
here on this podcast for free we really
hope you find value in what we've
created okay that's all for now enjoy
this audiobook episode of minimalism
live a meaningful life oh and one other
thing by the way if you haven't seen it
yet our documentary minimalism a
documentary about the important things
is finally available on Netflix starting
December 15th 2016 or if you don't have
Netflix you can still watch it on itunes
or amazon google play vimeo or DVD and
you can check out the beautiful trailer
to the film or find your preferred
viewing a platform over at minimalism
film.com okay really that that's it
for now for real we hope you enjoyed
this audiobook episode of minimalism
live a meaningful life
minimalism living meaningful life by the
minimalists chakra fields Melbourne and
Ryan Nicodemus read by Justin Moloch
music by we are you truly happy forward
a brief introduction conformity is the
drug with which many people
self-medicate not happy by this by that
by something keep up with the Joneses
the trumps the Kardashians after all you
can be just like them right clearly this
is wrong we all know this and yet we
continue to try day-in day-out we try we
try to keep up try to measure up try to
live up to societal expectations we
place immense pressure on ourselves to
be something or someone we are not
consequently people are more stressed
than ever we have more pressure put on
us than any other time in history you
see it on TV the toothpick thin models
and rugged sexiest men alive dominating
the screen this is what you're supposed
to look like you hear it on the radio
the solipsistic overindulgent Hummer
driving rap stars and champagne guzzling
pop stars promulgating irresponsible
living this is how you're supposed to
consume you notice it at work the
co-worker gossip about him and her and
god forbid you this is how you're
supposed to behave to have the tallest
building in town you must tear down
everyone else's suffice it to say the
pressure surrounds us or does it the
truth is that nearly all the pressure we
feel is completely internal sure this
pressure is influenced by external
factors but that doesn't mean we have to
take the bait we needn't succumb to
these influences because even if you
could be a Kardashian or a trump or a
Jones it wouldn't make you happy
happiness comes from within from inside
yourself from living a meaningful life
and that is what this book aims to help
you discover about the minimalists
this book is ultimately about you and
how you can live a meaningful life let's
talk about us for a moment
we are Joshua fields Melbourne and Ryan
Nicodemus a pair of 30-somethings who
write essays about living a meaningful
life with less stuff at the minimalist
calm a website with more than 4 million
readers our story has been featured on
The Today Show Wall Street Journal New
York Times USA Today Forbes
Time magazine People magazine and many
other outlets
we both have extensive experience
leading large groups of people in
corporate America coaching and
developing hundreds of employees to help
them grow as individuals and contribute
to the world around them once upon a
time we were two happy young
professionals living in Dayton Ohio
but we weren't truly happy we were best
friends in our late 20s and we both had
great six-figure jobs fancy cars big
houses expensive clothes plenty of toys
and abundance of stuff and yet with all
this stuff we knew we weren't satisfied
with our lives we weren't fulfilled we
discovered that working 70 or 80 hours a
week and buying even more stuff didn't
fill the void it widened it so we took
back control of our lives using the
principles of minimalism to focus on
what's important about this book this
book has been a long time in the making
its initial iteration conceived in 2010
and completed in March 2011 resulted in
a 300 page how-to guide called
minimalism in 21 days a 300 page book
about becoming a minimalist this didn't
feel right to us how could a book about
minimalism a book about reducing life
success be 300 pages we could almost
taste the irony don't get us wrong it
was a good book far better than most
drivel you'll find on the Internet but
because we in feel it was a great book
and because it lacked unnecessary
brevity we did what any responsible
authors would have done we scrapped the
entire project published an attenuated
version of minimalism in 21 days on our
website minimalist calm / 21 days it
started over with a blank page it was
difficult but it felt like the only
genuine way to create a meaningful book
the results was the first edition of
minimalism live a meaningful life
published in 2011 by asymmetrical press
much has happened and many lessons have
been learned in the 5 years since we
published that first edition
hence the book you are reading now the
second edition
of minimalism while rereading the short
book to write this updated edition we
were astonished by how well the books
principles have endured during every
event every interview and nearly every
conversation we have with readers we
find ourselves returning to the five
values in this book while we won't use
the pages of this new edition to expand
on the past half decade our memoir
everything that remains in our essay
collection essential to a thorough job
of that we significantly updated
minimalism by expanding on the five
values expressed in this book our
website provides the ultimate how to
start guide for free as well as frequent
updates by way of our online essays
which explore minimalism at a deep level
detailing practical ways to apply simple
living to your life we wrote this book
to be used in a similar practical way we
certainly don't want to waste your time
the ingredients in this book are
designed to provide you with a basic
recipe for intentional living while
allowing you to adjust the recipe to
suit your own tastes and lifestyle
furthermore while this entire book can
be consumed within a day or two it is
organized into seven six synced chunks
which are better digested in a week one
chapter at a time this book is different
from the content on our website and in
our other books while our website
documents our journey into minimalism
and our continued growth through
experimentation this book discusses
minimalism in a different way it covers
in depths the five values for living a
meaningful life it also provides insight
into our personal lives including the
painful events that led us to our
journey into minimalism the book itself
is written and organized to help you
think about your life and how you live
it to make you do some work and
introspection so you can step away from
your old life and journey into a new one
to help you realize you can change you
can reselect who you're going to be you
can become the best person you're
capable of becoming the real you the
passionate loving compassionate
disciplined happy you so if you truly
want to maximize what you learn from
this book we ask you not only read its
content
but also do three things as you read
read more than once
the first reading Prime's the pump but
rereading the parts you find most
relevant will fuel your desire to take
action to change your life take notes
unlike the essays on our website this
book is not designed to be read just
once and it is not a theoretical
document we want you to get the most out
this book which means taking notes
highlighting certain passages and making
lists to help you better understand
yourself take action this is the most
important step if you read this book but
do nothing with what you've learned then
you are wasting your time it's fine to
just absorb the information to start but
action is what's going to change your
life we don't overwhelm you with action
in these chapters but we do ask you to
make many small adjustments in your life
that add up to significant change over
time for all intents and purposes this
is a book of advice as minimalists we
start with the material possessions and
then once we've cleared the excess we
move beyond the stuff to the most
important aspects of life health
relationships passions growth and
contribution these five values are the
fundaments of living a meaningful life
finally it is important to note that
while we are sharing our 60 combined
years of living through these pages we
do not have all the answers the
strategies experiments and stories we
share in this book are things we've
learned from innumerable sources from
Elizabeth Gilbert to Tony Robbins and
everyone in between the common thread
however is that these are the strategies
that have worked well for us and
thousands of other people although we're
all different we're all looking for the
same thing how to live with more Meany
chapter 1 our arrival
are you happy the material possessions
we accumulate will not make us happy we
all know this and yet we often search
for life's meaning through accumulating
more possessions real happiness however
it comes from who we are from who we've
become real happiness comes from within
likewise discontentment is also a result
of who we've become if you want to base
your life on that of the average person
then this book is not for you because
the average person is not happy and just
because most people are unhappy doesn't
mean you must be unhappy too you needn't
settle for a mediocre life just because
the people around you did of course
happiness is not the point a meaningful
life is we must stop searching for
happiness and instead start looking for
meaning if our short term actions align
with our long term values we'll find
purpose in whatever we're doing
paradoxically it is this way of living
living deliberately that leads to true
happy
not ephemeral or fleeting happiness but
lasting contentment has reinforced by a
life of discipline attention awareness
and intentionality happiness is merely a
byproduct finding discontent in 2009
life looked great for both of us we both
worked for the same telecommunications
corporation
Joshua since 1999 Ryan since 2004 we
both enjoyed the perks of a lifestyle
most people envied we both lived our
version of the American Dream but for
some reason neither one of us could
explain at the time we were not happy we
didn't feel fulfilled and we certainly
didn't feel content the topic of
happiness began picking its head into
our conversations more frequently as
time passed with each promotion at work
with each award or a fancy trip we won
with every nugget of praise we received
the happiness accompanying those things
quickly came and went the faster I came
the faster left so we sought happiness
by attempting to get more of these
nuggets of praise trying to improve our
feelings of self-worth and significance
by quote unquote achieving more we
worked harder and harder to obtain these
affirmations of worth often working
twice as many hours as the average
American to prove our value it was
something like a cocaine high the more
praise we received the more we needed it
to function the more we needed it to
feel happy it got to the point where we
were living just to break even
emotionally discontent flooded our lives
we knew something needed to change but
we weren't sure what so we did what most
Americans do we tried to purchase
happiness even though we were both
earning more than six figures in
well-respected positions we spent more
money than we made purchasing things
like luxury cars large houses big-screen
TVs
fancy furniture expensive vacations and
everything else are heavily mediated
consumer culture told us would make us
happy but it didn't make us happy it
brought us more depression and
discontent because not only do the old
feelings stick around but we piled on to
those feelings by going into debt and
when the temporary high from each of our
purchases dissipated we were left
feeling depressed empty alone and
helpless then in late 2009 a series of
alarming events made Joshua begin to
question every aspect of his life
including his material possessions his
career his success and
meaning of life a slow burn but let's
rewind our story a bit because our
discontent didn't suddenly descend from
the heavens striking us like a bolt of
lightning we didn't wake up one morning
and say gee everything was fine
yesterday but today I'm unhappy
discontentment doesn't work that way
rather it's a slow burn it's a
pernicious problem that creeps into your
life after years of subtle
dissatisfaction it started when we were
young the first signs of discontent
appeared in our lives well before our
days in corporate America is started
when we were children the two of us met
20 years ago in the fifth grade we were
10 years old living near Dayton Ohio and
even by then our lives were filled with
discontent we both grew up in
dysfunctional households during the
1980s before dysfunctional was a common
term both sets of our parents were
divorced Joshua's parents separated when
he was three his mother succumbed to
alcoholism forcing him to raise himself
most years after age six his bipolar
schizophrenic father died when he was
nine Ryan's mother had similar substance
abuse issues which later led to
substance abuse for Ryan as a young
adult both of us were raised in less
than ideal conditions for much of our
childhoods which in retrospect was a
recipe for disaster
by age 12 we were both overweight uncool
and utterly unhappy with our lives we
did things to try to escape back then
the easiest escape was food we
experienced instant gratification by
stuffing our faces we felt certain we
would be happy at least for a moment
food was one of the few aspects of our
lives we could control because
everything else felt so out of control
we lived in dilapidated cockroach
infested apartments with single mothers
who cared about us but who were more
concerned with getting drunk or high
than providing for their children as we
approached high school Ryan moved into
his father's home a much Stabler
household his father owned a small
wallpapering company and was able to
provide a better lower middle-class
lifestyle Ryan's father was the
antithesis of his mother he held a
stable job he showed he cared in myriad
ways and he was a devout Jehovah's
Witness the long list of positive
changes was too much for Ryan to handle
all at once so while he did his best to
conform to the strict household rules
he also rebelled experimenting with
alcohol marijuana and harder drugs
Joshua took a different route
while he didn't indulge in alcohol or
drugs because he was so turned off by
his mother's ramp into alcoholism he
found another way to cope namely
obsession and compulsion in the form of
OCD he discovered that even though he
couldn't control his a living situation
the tumbledown apartment
the drunken mother the lack of money he
could control himself so he lost a lot
of weight during his freshman year in
high school in an unhealthy way by
eating very little and he spent hours
organizing his meager possessions
obsessing over the smallest things
searching for some kind of order in a
world of chaos during our last year of
high school in 1998 we had a memorable
conversation that unknowingly became the
tipping point that led us into the chaos
and confusion of consumerism because we
grew up relatively poorer we thought the
key to our happiness would be money
specifically if we could just make fifty
thousand dollars a year then we'd be set
our parents hadn't earned that kind of
money and they weren't happy so we
figured if we could pass an arbitrary
threshold fifty thousand dollars in this
case then we would somehow be happy it
sounds ridiculous now but it made
perfect sense to a couple eighteen year
olds about to enter the world on their
own we graduated high school in 1999 and
we went in separate directions for a few
years neither of us went to college
straight away instead we both entered
the working world Ryan worked for his
father in wallpaper and painting walls
and opulent houses throughout Southwest
Ohio joshua found a sales job with a
large corporation both couriers were
steeped in certain monetary expectations
neither of us particularly enjoyed what
we were doing but we didn't know any
better we didn't realize he could
actually do work you enjoyed for us our
jobs were designed to do two things for
our lifestyle allow us to make money and
give us a certain kind of social status
Ryan was making enough money to live it
wasn't great money but it paid the bills
he also earned an identity from his job
a fleet of half a dozen paint trucks
nicodemus plastered on the side of each
patrolled the streets of Warren County
Ohio silently speaking volumes about his
future there was comfort in knowing that
one day he would take over his father's
business making it his own and maybe
even passing it on to his future
children but Ryan also knew the painting
business wouldn't make him rich he was
painting multi-million dollar homes
which he knew he'd never afford himself
even when he took over his dad's
business which if he worked really hard
you do once his dad retired in a decade
or two there was a fair amount of
discontent that showed up for Ryan
realizing he would never be able to get
something he wanted at the time he
didn't know why he wanted a palatial
home or why it would make him happy he
was merely unhappy that he would never
afford such luxuries so Ryan searched
for contentment in other ways Joshua
found a job at which he had the
potential to earn more money than the
people with whom he went to high school
a job that had long-term career growth
possibilities all he had to do was work
like a sled dog to quote unquote get
results so work like a dog he did often
working more than a month straight seven
days a week without a day off the more
he worked the more he sold and the more
he sold the more money he earned and the
more he was showered with praise at 18
he was already making more money than
his mother ever had he was poised for
corporate greatness at least ostensibly
but Joshua experienced his content too
although he was making more than $50,000
by nineteen he had little personal time
the corporate world of performing and
achieving was taking his toll so he
tried to purchase happiness attempting
to manufacture a life of contentment
manufactured contentment unhappy with
our jobs and our lives we tried to fix
our discontent in different ways Ryan
turned to a few extremes first he turned
back to his father's religion the
religion of his childhood swearing off
drugs and worldly activities becoming a
devout Jehovah's Witness embracing his
tenets and searching for life's meaning
through a religion Ryan married his high
school girlfriend at 18 a few months
after graduating high school he and his
wife adopted the JW lifestyle got a
mortgage for a small house in the
hometown in which they were raised and
started talking about creating a family
together but it became a marriage
saturated with fear and distrust after
three years of tedious matrimony the
marriage ended nastily upon which Ryan
turned back to drugs and alcohol
searching for an escaped from his
painful failed reality Joshua on the
other hand continued his laser-focused
work in corporate America consistently
performing as one of the best
salespeople in the company he earned his
first promotion to a leadership position
at 22 making him the youngest person in
the company's 130 year history to have
earned the position with his promotion
came more money more responsibilities
and even more work Joshua's life was
consumed by work at 23 he got married
built a large house in suburbia and
continued to work more and more as his
personal life passed by and the
unfocused background he hardly realized
he had gotten married he neglected and
took for granted the relationship with
his wife he hardly spent time in a large
house which contained more bedrooms and
inhabitants above all he avoided the
discontent brewing within him he knew he
wasn't happy but he'd get there one day
right and so life went on at its
breakneck pace to deal with his more
subtle discontent
Joshua tried to buy his happiness he
spent money on stuff buying fancy
clothes expensive vacations consumer
electronics multitudes of unnecessary
junk when those things didn't bring
lasting happiness he turned to his
childhood vice of food by his early 20s
he weighed more than ever he was 70
pounds overweight and severely out of
shape but at least I'm making money he
thought giving himself an identity in
his career the kind of status and
satisfaction and knowing he performed
well at his job I'll be at a job he
wasn't passionate about reconnecting the
duo it was around this time that we
reconnected almost accidentally at the
nadir of our early 20s Ryan decided that
taking over his father's business was
not for him he didn't know what he
wanted to do with his life but he
figured he'd give the corporate world a
shot peace if he could just make over
$50,000 a year then life would be good
and he would be happy right so in 2004
shortly after Joshua got married and
Ryan got divorced Joshua hired Ryan to
work at the corporation at which he had
slayed for the last half decade like
Joshua Ryan quickly excelled working
exceptionally hard becoming one of the
company's top performing salespeople we
both earned several more promotions over
the years during our mid and late 20s
promotions with fancy titles like
channel manager regional manager and
director and with those titles came more
money and more responsibilities and more
work sadly far darker things came with
those promotions as well anxiety and
stress and worry and overwhelm and
depression and yet try as we did our
search for happiness through status and
material possessions never yielded real
lasting happiness or contentment by
early 20s we were earning great money at
jobs we disliked
but we were in debt financially and
emotionally back to the future
fast-forward back to 2009 back to our 80
hour work weeks back to our ostensibly
perfect lives that were crumbling on the
inside on October 8th 2009 Joshua's
mother died of stage 4 lung cancer she
battled it over a year
enduring repeat chemo and radiation
treatments but as the cancer spread to
her brain and other organs she was no
match for the disease in the end
oddly enough the cancer seemed to be a
metaphor for Joshua's life while things
looked good on the surface the marriage
the fancy job the cars the trinkets of
success there was something seriously
wrong on the inside neither of us was
happy when we told ourselves a decade
earlier we'd be happy if we could just
make $50,000 per year we were wrong at
first in our early 20s we thought maybe
we had simply miscalculated the exact
amount required to be happy so we
changed our estimation if we can make
$60,000 per year then we could be happy
right and when that didn't work if we
can make $75,000 and then $90,000 and
$100,000 per year then we could be happy
right it was a never-ending cycle each
year we made more money in each year we
spent more than we earn din an effort to
subdue our perpetual discontent created
by the lifestyles we were living the
equation itself was broken a week after
Joshua's mother died we had another
conversation about happiness we
discussed why we weren't happy and what
it would take to make us happy obviously
the old formula of if we can make X
dollars then we could be happy was not
panning out we were both making over six
figures
we were both successful 28 year old
young executives and we both quote
unquote had it figured out according to
cultural standards but we didn't have it
figured out at all was this what we had
been waiting for our entire lives where
we going to continue to work
ridiculously long hours at a corporation
that didn't care about us were we going
to work our way into upper management
becoming CEO OHS or CEOs with seven or
eight figure salaries just to be even
more depressed by the time we were in
our 40s it didn't sound appealing to us
our dreams of climbing the corporate
ladder seem more like nightmares the
more we talked about it the death of
Joshua's mother put everything into
perspective we have only a finite amount
of time on this earth
can be spent accumulating monetary
wealth or it can be spent in a
meaningful way the latter of which
doesn't necessarily preclude someone
from the former but the relentless
pursuit of riches doesn't lead to a
meaningful life so we decided to take an
inventory of our lives we wanted to find
out what was making us unhappy and what
we needed to do to change those things
in our lives so we could experience
happiness passion freedom anchors first
we identified our anchors we had
discovered getting what we wanted large
houses bigger paychecks material
possessions and corporate awards wasn't
making us happy so he wanted identify
what was anchoring us what was making us
feel stuck and preventing us from
growing the concept of anchors struck a
chord with both of us it forced us to
take an honest look in the mirror and
identify everything we thought might be
holding us back from living happy
fulfilled lives the exercise we
performed was simple over the course of
one week each of us wrote down anything
we thought might be an anchor the first
step to solving a problem is to identify
the problem right as the week progressed
our lists of anchors grew and by the end
of the week Josh wood counted
eighty-three anchors and Ryan 54 plenty
of anchors our next step was to identify
our priorities we started prioritizing
by dividing our anchors into two
categories
major anchors and minor anchors major
anchors were the most obvious things
keeping us from feeling free including
our houses namely the large mortgage
payments that went with them certain
relationships with people namely
unhealthy relationships that didn't add
value to our lives car payments and
other large bills major debts our
careers and anything else that demanded
an inordinate amount of time without
returning commensurate value to our
lives
minor anchors made up the bulk of our
lists and included cable bills internet
bills other bills smaller debts unused
clothes unused household items household
clutter certain unproductive peripheral
relationships daily drive time and other
small things that consumed small amounts
of our time attention and focus we
decided that ridding ourselves of many
of these anchors over a period of time
will let us reclaim much of our own time
which could then be spent in more
meaningful ways because the major
anchors appear to be the hardest to
tackle we started with those first for
example every extra penny
for earned was spent on making extra
payments toward his debts no more trips
vacations or fancy dinners all his money
went toward paying off his car and his
vast credit card debt which despite
healthy income had climbed to an
unbelievable level greater than six
figures eventually over a two-year
period we paid off our cars and paid
down our debts other major anchors were
addressed in a similar fashion we
eventually jettisoned many of our
possessions eliminating the excess in
favour of things we liked and enjoyed
things we actually used in our daily
lives over the course of two years our
anchors of old were no longer weighing
us down making difficult decisions
because some of the major anchors
involved our relationships with other
people some tough decisions had to be
made soon after Joshua's mother died
Shaffer decided his marriage of nearly
60 years wasn't working he knew that
neither he nor his wife was happy that
neither of their values or desires were
aligned and that they both wanted vastly
different things from life they loved
each other and wanted to find a way to
make their marriage work so they sat
down and discussed their differences and
worked on a plan to save their marriage
they attended marriage counseling and
took steps to come into better alignment
working together for months in an effort
to repair a broken marriage their
differences however were too great so
Joshua and his wife decided to part ways
it was the hardest decision he ever had
to make
thankfully as time passed they were able
to remain close friends who still care
about each other deeply furthermore Josh
was faced with the dilemma of what to do
with his mother's stuff after her death
what to do with those sentimental items
we tend to hold on to in perpetuity his
mother had lived a thousand miles away
in Florida and after she passed it was
his responsibility to vacate her small
one-bedroom apartment brimming with
belongings his mother had an interior
decorators good taste so none of her
stuff was junked in the hoarders sense
of the word which means letting go of
anything difficult nevertheless there
was a lot of stuff in her home likely
three or more apartments as worse than
her tiny dwelling so he knew some things
would have to go his mom had lived her
life as a constant shopper I was
accumulating more stuff she didn't eat
furniture throughout her apartment
a stunning oak canopy bed that consumed
almost her entire bedroom two closets
bulging with clothes picture frames
standing on every flat surface orig
artwork hanging on the walls and
creative decorations in every nook and
cranny and crevice 64 years of
accumulations so Joshua did what any son
would do he rented a large u-haul truck
then he called a storage facility back
in Ohio to make sure they had a big
enough storage unit
the truck was $1,600 the storage
facility was $120 per month
financially the cost was expensive but
he quickly discovered the emotional cost
was much higher at first shots were
didn't want to let go of anything if
you've lost a loved one or you've been
through a similarly emotional time then
you understand exactly how hard it was
for him to let go of any of those
possessions so instead of letting go he
planned to cram every trinket and
figurine and piece of oversized
furniture into that tiny storage locker
in Ohio floor to ceiling that way he
knew mom's stuff was there if he ever
wanted it if you ever needed access to
it for some incomprehensible reason just
in case the week after her death Joshua
began boxing up her belongings every
picture frame every porcelain doll every
doily on every shelf he packed every bit
of earth that remained or so he thought
then he looked under the bed among the
organized chaos ty compromised a crawl
space beneath her bed there were four
boxes each label with a number one two
three four each numbered box was sealed
with packing tape Josh will cut through
the tape and found old papers from his
elementary school days grades one
through four spelling tests cursive
writing lessons artwork it was all there
every shred of paper from his first four
years of school it was evident she and
access the sealed boxes in years and yet
she had held on to these things because
she was trying to hold on to pieces of
her son pieces of the past much like
Joshua was attempting to hold on to
pieces of her in her past now that's
when he realized his retention efforts
were futile he could hold on to her
memories without her stuff just as she
had always remembered him and his
childhood and all their memories without
ever accessing those sealed boxes under
her bed she didn't need papers from 25
years ago to remember her son just as
her son didn't need a storage locker
filled with her belongings to remember
her so Joshua called u-haul and
cancelled the truck then over the next
12 days he donated almost all her stuff
to places and people who could actually
use it of course it was difficult to
like
but Joshua learned several lessons
during this experience we are not our
stuff we are more than our possessions
our memories are within us not our
things our stuff weighs on us mentally
and emotionally old photographs can be
scanned you can take pictures of items
you want to remember items that are
sentimental for us can be useful to
others
letting go is freeing we don't think
sentimental items are bad or evil or
that holding onto them is wrong rather
we think the maligned nature of
sentimental items is far more subtle if
you want to get rid of an item but the
only reason you are holding on to it
it's for sentimental reasons if it's
weighing on you if it's an anchor then
perhaps it's time to get rid of it
perhaps it's time to free yourself of
the weight that doesn't mean you need to
get rid of everything though one by one
over time the two of us tackled many of
our angers big and small in the process
of tackling our anchors we search for
ways to do so more efficiently we search
for examples of people who had overcome
their fears who had freed themselves of
their anchors and started living more
meaningful lives this is how we stumbled
upon the concepts of minimalism
discovering minimalism in late 2009
shortly after Joshua's mother had died
while his marriage was in shambles and
we were both unhappy with our current
nose to the grindstone situations joshua
came across a website called exiled
lifestyle developed by a guy named Colin
right we were intrigued by Colin's
website here was this young 24 year old
entrepreneur living an amazing life a
seemingly impossible life
he left his high-paying career to pursue
his passions traveling the world and
running his businesses from anywhere his
website what he called a blog a term we
were unfamiliar with at the time
documented his travels and allowed his
thousands of readers to participate in
his journey Colin's readers vote on
where he will travel next we were amazed
that this guy left everything to travel
to a new country every four months now
that we wanted to travel that
extensively ourselves we didn't but we
didn't want to have the freedom to
pursue our own passions which we
discovered weren't inside the corporate
juggernaut Colin also used a term with
which we were utterly unfamiliar he said
he was a minimalist on his website he
wrote about how this movement called
minimalism allowed him to focus on the
important stuff in his life while
shedding the excess
junk that gotten in the way this was
fascinating it was like someone turned
on the light bulb for us for the first
time and presented us with a tool to
help us weed through the clutter in our
lives to finally get to what was
important because he traveled town owned
only 72 things at the time there were
pictures of all his possessions on his
website and all of his possessions fit
into a bag he carried with him while he
traveled the most striking part about
this story was Colin's contentment he
exuded happiness and excitement and
passion he loved his life although we
deeply respect Colin we didn't want to
live like him we didn't want to travel
the world or live with fewer than a
hundred things but we didn't want the
freedom that his minimalist lifestyle
afforded him and we wanted the happiness
and passion that accompanied that
freedom so during the first half of 2010
we slowly removed our anchors one by one
as we followed Colin's journey but at 30
maybe we were too old and too rooted to
become minimalist maybe this minimalism
thing was only for young guys without
many possessions who wanted to travel
extensively we discovered that wasn't
true either through Colin we discovered
two other minimalists who were in many
ways much like us leo bababa and Joshua
Becker Leo bababa creator of the website
Zen habits had a story that resonated
with us immediately he was a once
divorced a man in his mid-30s who
overcame scads of adversity to live more
meaningfully using minimalism to
simplify his life he had accomplished
some amazing feats in just a few years
he quit smoking lost 70 pounds gotten
into the best shape of his life climbed
out of debt moved from Guam to San
Francisco and quit his corporate job but
was still able to provide for his wife
and six children
similarly 30-something Joshua Becker a
husband and father of two living in
Vermont simplified a suburban family
life using minimalism while maintaining
his job at a local church and helping
other people learn more about minimalism
through his web site becoming minimalist
Leo Bovada and Joshua Becker proved to
us minimalism wasn't only for single
guys who didn't want to work on
nine-to-five it was for anyone
interested in living a simpler more
intentional life it was for anyone who
wanted to focus on the important aspects
in life rather than the material
possessions so heavily linked to success
and happiness by our culture in fact on
our website we have a page dedicated to
defining minimalism in a tongue-in-cheek
way
poking fun at the cynics and skeptics
who treat minimalism as a trend or fad
we start our definition with to be a
minimalist you must live with fewer than
a hundred things and you can't own a car
or a home or a TV and you can't have a
career and you have to be able to live
in exotic places all over the world and
you have to write a blog and you can't
have children and you have to be a young
white male from a privileged background
okay we're joking obviously but people
who dismiss minimalism as a fad usually
mentioned some of the above
quote-unquote restrictions as to why
they could quote-unquote never be a
minimalist the truth is minimalism isn't
about any of those things but it can
help you accomplish almost all that
stuff if you're so inclined if you
desire to live with fewer than a hundred
things or not own a car or travel all
over the world minimalism can't help but
that's not the point the point is
minimalism is a tool to help you achieve
freedom freedom from fear freedom from
worry
freedom from overwhelm freedom from
guilt freedom from depression freedom
from enslavement freedom real freedom a
minimalist can however own a car and a
house and have children and a career
minimalism looks different for everyone
because it's about finding what is
essential to you there are tons of
successful minimalist who do some or all
of these things seem minimalist calm
slash links for a list of minimalist so
how can they all be so different and yet
still be minimalist that brings us back
to our original question what is
minimalism minimalism is a tool we use
to live a meaningful life there are no
rules rather minimalism is simply about
stripping away the unnecessary things in
your life so you can focus on what's
important ultimately minimalism is the
thing that gets us past the things so we
can focus on life's most important
things which actually aren't things at
all minimalism has helped us in several
ways including reclaiming our time
ridding ourselves of excess stuff
enjoying our lives
discovering meaning in our lives living
in the moment focusing on what's
important pursuing our passions finding
happiness doing anything we want to do
finding our missions experiencing
freedom creating more consuming less
house minimalism helped us with these
things minimalism is a lifestyle choice
minimalist choose to get rid of the
unnecessary in favor of what's important
but the level of specify
city is up to you minimalist search for
happiness not through things but through
life itself thus it's up to you to
determine what is necessary and what is
superfluous to your life throughout this
book we will give you some ideas of how
to determine these things and how to
achieve a minimalist lifestyle without
succumbing to a strict code or a set of
rules a word of warning it isn't easy to
take the first few steps but the journey
gets much easier and more rewarding the
further you go but the first steps into
minimalism often take radical changes in
mindset actions and habits so if we had
to sum it up in one sentence we would
say minimalism is a tool to eliminate
life's excess focus on the essentials
and find happiness fulfillment and
freedom embracing minimalism it was as
our lives were spiraling downward and
ever diminishing circles toward oblivion
that we embrace minimalism it was a
beacon in the night we feverishly
scoured internet page after Internet
page looking for more information and
guidance and enlightenment watching and
learning and trying to understand what
this whole minimalism thing was about
through months of research while we
removed our anchors we traveled further
and further down the rabbit hole and
over time we discovered a group of
people without a lot of things but with
myriad happiness and passion and freedom
things for which we desperately yearned
eventually we embraced these concepts
the concepts of minimalism and
simplicity as a way of life and we
discovered we too could be happy but it
wasn't through owning more stuff it
wasn't through accumulation we took back
control of our lives so we could focus
on what's important so we could focus on
life's deeper meaning happiness as far
as we are concerned is achieved
internally through living a meaningful
life a life that is filled with passion
and freedom a life in which we can grow
and contribute to others in meaningful
ways these are the bedrocks of happiness
not stuff creating the minimalists in
the summer of 2010 we had no intentions
of writing nonfiction online or starting
a website about minimalism but then
almost accidentally Joshua met Colin
right in person while on a trip to New
York City in June meeting Colin
solidified his online persona his
personality shown through in-person
displaying layers of happiness and
contentment that didn't seem possible to
a discontented man approaching 30 living
on the corporate continuum
they met in Manhattan after connecting
on Twitter Joshua had been writing
fiction throughout his 20s whenever he
had a free moment outside of work
he knew Colin hurt a living online by
publishing his own material so he wanted
to pick Colin's brain about
self-publishing when they met for lunch
Colin encouraged Josh would explore the
non-traditional route of publishing his
fiction citing several resources that
would later become helpful see
asymmetrical Cove slash how - - for a
list of resources they stayed in contact
after that initial meeting and
eventually worked on several projects
together including Colin's memoir my
exiled lifestyle and Joshua's novel as a
decade fades during that meeting Colin
said one thing that stuck with Joshua
the one thing that led him to team up
with Ryan to create the minimalists you
should do something online you could
make a difference the world needs people
like you to help them see things clearly
Josh wrote those words in his journal
they stuck with him long after the
meeting and with those words we decided
to create the minimalists we wanted to
do two things with our website we wanted
to document our personal journeys into
minimalism and we wanted to help other
people live more meaningful lives using
minimalism as a foundation we started
building the site in November 2010 and
quickly discover we were clueless about
how to create a website we didn't know
the first thing about HTML or blogging
or writing nonfiction online sure Joshua
had his fiction writing experience which
helped with our writing but we were
clueless about the rest so we did
extensive research and built our site
over a six-week time frame labouring
vigorously until the last minute for an
in-depth look at how we created our
website read our essay how to start a
successful blog at minimalist com slash
blog we officially launched the
minimalist calm on December 14 2010 and
so there we were to suit and tie
corporate guys taking advice from some
millennial bloggers
we started a website documented our
entire journey into minimalism and start
writing a few essays a week for the site
then several months of unexpected
excitement transpired and our lives
changed within nine months of creating
our website we met some of the most
amazing people on the Internet
eventually turning those online
relationships into real life friendships
including the aforementioned Leo by
Buddha and Joshua Becker as well as
myriad others among them Jillian Smith
Chris Gila beau and Courtney Carver
with the help of many of these
outstanding folks as well as our small
number of initial readers for
relentlessly sharing our essays our
website grew exponentially within nine
months we had over 100,000 monthly
readers by that time people were
spending over 11,000 hours on our site
each month we had been featured on
popular websites all over the web
we received the most incredible emails
about how we changed people's lives with
our essays as a consequence we both left
our corporate jobs and began focusing
full-time on living more meaningful
lives to read more about our eggs-it
from the corporate world read chapter
seven of our memoir everything that
remains or Joshua's essay why I walked
away from my six-figure career at
minimalist calm slash quit what it means
to live a meaningful life what does it
mean to live a meaningful life generally
through our essays and books we speak of
minimalism as a tool that has allowed us
to pursue more meaningful lives so it's
important we define what this means
after much celebration deliberation
discussion research and experimentation
we discovered five values that allow us
to live a meaningful life number one
health number two relationships number
three passions number four growth number
five contribution it took us months of
removing the anchors from our lives and
getting rid of the clutter that
surrounded us to uncover these five
values we didn't stumble into them
though instead we discover what was most
important in our lives through trial and
error minimalism made this discovery
possible by twenty eight everything in
our lives seemed foggy we had everything
we were supposed to have everything our
culture advertised would make us happy
and yet we weren't worse we had reached
the point at which we didn't know what
was important anymore
getting rid of the clutter in our lives
allowed us to rediscover these five key
areas thus getting rid of our stuff was
the initial bite at the Apple allowing
us to make a room to fill our lives with
more meaningful pursuits through months
of rigorous documentation the five
values are the areas we change in our
lives that have the largest positive
effect and resulted in more satisfaction
and contentment for the two of us the
following five chapters discuss each of
these concepts in depth much more so
than can be discussed on our website
throughout these chapters we consider
why these five values are the most
important areas of our lives and how
minimalism has allowed us to focus on
these values citing personal example
of how we changed our lives in all five
areas the books final chapter confluence
binds together these five values and
asks the reader some important questions
about their life these questions are not
rhetorical they are meant to make you
think take notes and make a list based
on those questions similarly as we
stated in the books forward we encourage
you to actively engage in all the
chapters by reading the content more
than once writing notes in the margins
highlighting meaningful passages making
your own lists and most important taking
action ultimately this book is meant to
make you take little actions each day
that will radically improve your life
over time let's begin shall we
[Music]
funnily
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners this is Kristin
from Asheville North Carolina and I was
listening to your podcast talking about
unwrapping the banana and I just had
another idea to give experiences to kids
I was thinking why don't you put in
little mini gift bags a card gift card
for a family movie night or even little
invitations like one dinner date with
mommy
one long walk with Daddy
whatever the case just make them family
experiences almost like coupons but put
them in little gift bags my name is
Jamie Hembree I am from Shawnee Oklahoma
there have been a lot of questions about
how to navigate gift-giving and children
on a number of the podcast not just the
holiday podcast and I wanted to share a
tip my mom did when I was growing up
that tremendously impacted me and
instilled some of the same values that
we often talk about with minimalism I
was always allowed to ask for anything I
wanted but my mother was paused and
asked me that's fine we can get that but
what is it that you're willing to give
up or give away in order to make space
for the new item so I often had to
choose something that I already loved
and just taking the time as a child to
pause and decide what is the new thing I
loved more and it was worth getting rid
of the thing I already had in love would
make me not want the new thing otherwise
I was always allowed to pick an event or
an activity to go do in lieu of a
material gift where I kept my current
position and we would go to a movie or
my favorite restaurant or the zoo
hey Josh and Ryan this is Jared McDaniel
from Chattanooga Tennessee I was just
calling in response to your holiday
episode just listen to it and as always
a great stuff thanks for sharing and
specifically wanted to comment about how
to talk to kids about
santa claus so my daughter is only a
year old so i haven't played with it yet
but what my parents did with my brother
and i in hindsight thinking about how
the parent was actually really really
cool so what they did was they didn't
have a hard line of yes santa claus real
or no Santa Claus isn't real so we were
the kids at school saying you know I
stand it's causing a real breaking
everybody's heart so what they said was
that Santa Claus represented the spirit
of giving and so that was pretty neat
because that allowed us to kind of let
our childhood imagination enjoy the you
know some of the magic of the holidays
and things that that that you get to you
as a kid and it also had the positive
connotation at the holidays and things
around the holidays or more about what
we can give as opposed to receive and so
in hindsight I think it is a pretty good
job of going about it that way and just
learn to share and taste that add value
to anybody else all right Joe that's it
for this episode if you have a question
for the minimalists give us a call for 0
6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening yeah we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'd be fine
without it
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grin oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
[Music]
you
[Music]